it is time for hatred mail if you've
never seen or heard hatred mail here is
what it is we're so all right it's wrong
Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom it's pretty difficult to
argue with this week's hatred mail and I
think you'll understand why as soon as
you hear it
Trump has done more for this country in
the past six months then the three
previous presidents did in their whole
careers dim send old left are lying
swamp corruption Trump has lowest
unemployment in 16 years GDP is finally
up to 2.6 percent
Dow Jones 22 K a record ms-13 getting
deported signed over 40 bills helping
deregulating businesses tax reform and
infrastructure are next and Obamacare is
on the House and Senate you flipped arts
need to quit deluding yourselves like
you did around the election of that
[ __ ] Hillary I believe Trump's 33
percent approval rating is about as
dependable as Hillary that is going to
win the election and unless Muller has a
video of Trump murdering someone with
his bare hands good luck with
impeachment and getting two-thirds of a
Republican House and Senate to back it
kaku kaku kaku kaku
you know I wouldn't go around admitting
that Trump can do anything and his
supporters and Republicans will continue
to support him that's not exactly praise
you're not exactly indicating that your
electorate your constituents are
informed reasonable people if you're
effectively saying that Trump could do
anything short of murder and they would
not abandon him and I like the Kaakha
Kaakha Kaakha Kaakha that i've never
been called that before I've been called
a Jew [ __ ]
I've been called something else that
sounds like [ __ ] but relates to being
Jewish but never a Kaakha Kaakha Kaakha
[ __ ] and that makes me more forcefully
tell you that you can turn hatred mail
into something
positive there is a coupon code it's hey
tree at 40 if you use that coupon code
at david pakman.com slash membership you
can get a membership for 40% off and
using the coupon code hey tree at 40 is
sort of like a middle finger to the
hatreds